while ABC contemplates their next move  after pulling GMA co-anchors TJ Holmes  and Amy roback off the air amid  allegations of their Affair multiple  sources are coming forward alleging that  TJ cheated on his wife merrily with  other women from Good Morning America  over the years yeah according to page  six TJ had at least one other Affair in  addition to his relationship with Amy  and producer Natasha Singh you know it's  too bad it's Friday it's been a great  week we just want this one to keep going  and going and going although ABC has  declined to comment an Insider tells  page six that quote TJ's cheating with  ABC staffers was definitely one of the  reasons why they were yanked off it has  become a distraction on Monday it was  reported that ABC News president Kim  Godwin announced during an internal call  that both TJ and Amy will no longer  continue their daily show as it has  become too much of an internal and  external distraction